it's a very powerful judgement and it is
incredible in one sense that the judges
have got into this space use the
language they have saying that
essentially the Prime Minister his real
motive was to frustrate the process and
to shut down Parliament across the
country I don't think many people
actually believe the Prime Minister when
he said this is just for a Queen's
speech but for a court to say that the
documents really point one way and that
they undermine his case to a point where
they've ruled him unlawful that's an
incredibly powerful thing for them to
have done Jonah cherry and the others
lost at first I think in the High Court
in Scotland this was the appeal and of
course the government's now going to
appeal to the Supreme Court in London
you're a former DPP you know about these
things what are you expecting in the
Supreme Court well what the Supreme
Court would come to its own decision but
don't underestimate this I mean courts
quite used to saying that government's
acted unlawfully because they've
misinterpreted the law or something like
that that's not unusual but to say that
the motive or the reason the primest has
put forward was not the true reason that
is very powerful and very unusual for a
court I don't think they would have done
it without overwhelming evidence and I
actually think that the right thing for
the Prime Minister now is to recall
Parliament this afternoon or tomorrow
morning so that we can get back do our
job and look at the judgments as a
parliament and decide what ought to
happen next can he do